direction le commissariat d'elancourt
accompagné de la sénatrice des yvelines
sophie primas le président du sénat a pu
constater lui même l'état de dégradation
du bâtiment 320 policiers y travaillent
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ce
commissaire comment vous vous le trouvez
urgence c'est sans doute la première
urgence des yvelines de pas simplement
rénover mais de construire un nouvel
hôtel de police qui servent à l'ensemble
de la circonscription les conditions
dans lequel travail des fonctionnaires
de police
et j'allais dire inadmissible la
rénovation de ce commissariat
d'agglomération est un dossier vieux de
20 ans mais les choses semblent
progresser en décembre valérie pécresse
avait annoncé que la région
ile-de-france financerait une partie des
travaux mon humour est bien sûr
satisfait de voir que le président du
sénat bien sûr aussi est sensible à
cette structure
en plus on agir et bien entendu la
sensibilité de trappes la verrière qui
sont quand même des communes classées un
peu sensible donc
donc mobilisation en tout cas général le
président du sénat a poursuivi sa visite
à l'école vibrante d'elancourt dans
cette classe tous les enfants des gaines
fièrement leurs tablettes
le numérique est au coeur de la
pédagogie on est ici dans une école qui
prépare le futur
il ya les enfants viennent l'entente qui
vont assez facilement au sol et ceux qui
ont besoin d'un soutien et le numérique
semble et apporter la journée s'est
enfin achevée par une rencontre avec les
élus de la ville où ont été abordés
d'autres sujets comme le logement